i ragazzi oggi siamo tornati su una
perla ovviamente del canale che ogni
tanto di facile rimane una volta al mese
cioè la devo buttare dentro ore perché
tipo mi manca starò ma non so perché lo
faccio che esser è uno dei primi video
ragazzi che faccio con la camera arma
che miley o quasi ultimato il mio studio
adesso bella frontale
be nice vediamo subito di far vedere la
mia ignoranza con famous places i maya
ragazzi non ho la minima idea di dove
siano lì dove siano i reperti mai a
breve mi ai vecchi pro sono uguali i
nostri video appello dico sempre
effettivamente però prima o poi qualcuno
le avrà guardati non stava in qua qua
più o meno yucatan certo cioè fino a me
export silvio siamo ovviamente a casa la
mappa di compiuti a parte gli scherzi
allora teoricamente altro qua diciamo
fatto eccolo qui c'è un negozio di
souvenir avevo fatto un video in live ai
tempi bellissimo ragazzi siamo a londra
e siamo al si chiama posto miglioramento
quello piccadilly
non ho la mia idea per ogni dove sia
piccadilly e con il discorso di giuro
che non mi ricordo non ho la minima
proprio ideali dove sia perché si sa
piccadilly vittoria james park place the
decade a lei l'ex viola siamo nel mezzo
che anche l'incrocio importante non
quindi aspettati anche capisco questa
attraversando la strada che cazzo ne so
quindi questa la stazione ok
quell'incrocio è questo qua qua
porca vacca o sbagliato dalla lava vesta
o 28 metri e grossa picca di virus
dall'altra parte tutto sbagliato ma fa
niente l'importante che azzeccato vicari
già quello miracolo mi scusi lui lui
data e batman semplicemente ce l'ha
appoggiato qua il mantello me batman
allora credo che sia una chiesa in onore
per principi sa post qualche borghesi
sul romanzo credo che è star da che
stiamo così non posso muovermi morso
muovermi non posso muovermi benissimo
potrebbe essere il vaticano però non ne
sono proprio sicurissimi stimo proprio
sicura di 0,02 per cento
secondo me siamo tipo tipo qua ma non ne
sono sicurissimo che ci provo
era giusto ma inizio ne stava un po più
in là porco del demonio vabbe dai ampia
comunque la zona è sempre quella sono
andato molto bravo e ragga palacio
nasari es
non ho la mia attenzione però c'era la
via porcaccia banca ma lasci una serie
al casa ma credo che sia in spagna però
non la minima idea di dove sia quindi
vado sul siviglia non ho la minima la
minima idea di che cacchio di cosa
stiamo parlando
non era anche a granada la vela è più o
meno 0 però è comunque a me c'era in
spagna lo sa se capi almeno quello
queste colonne a milano credo si parla
comunque di un della grecia sicuro però
sto bene
esattamente dove c'è la vela collina
vero grecia qua ma porca put oraria
questo nomi se questo vi sembra tutto
meno che famoso processo con te l'ho
vista anche a milano marittima 9 milano
marittima faccia vede che non l'avevo
già vista che l'avevo già beccato in un
gioco che essere il monte rushmore mai
non ho idea di dove sia il monte
rushmore cioè mi pare che fosse nel in
un posto totalmente a cars c'è veramente
mondo noi da lì dove sia poi nel wyoming
cioè no veramente ragazzi non so dove
sia il notw erasmo non so più qual era
il sud da cosa farà l'avrei mai azzecca
mai azzeccato fidatevi mai o bellissimo
va bene allora per forza ragazzi che mi
esce venezia c'è sempre qualcuno di
venezia invece no come fatto sbagliare
il canale vaio che cazzo ne sono di
canale n'è uno solo per ora no non so
quale sia ragazze come cacchio faccio io
non sono di venezia uno vale l'altro per
me è ok ok ok ok ok
proprio lui 202 metri porca [ __ ] prova
beh almeno il canale da quello dei
ragazzi di cambiare i posti famosi
perché sennò è veramente troppo semplice
finalmente adesso sì che c'è chi si auto
gara auto calcolo che faccio con rocket
l'ing non solo siamo ma anche qui ogni
giorno è speso bene rasmus codreanu
potrebbe essere romania top c'è mai boom
di europa romania romani ha visto le
rose camion e romania e fin qua ci siamo
pronuncio dove e romania angela se mi
chiedi chi è
io dico che c'è in romania però non so
dove sia bucarest il rumore provoca che
ne sorega dovesse qualsiasi posto in
romania facciamo esattamente bucarest e
in questa via con manush douglas off
vabbè dai 145 km non male roma 6 lug
ragazzi in europa perché ho messo europa
è quindi vado andrebbe dubbi che questo
posto salamandre tipo news
stamane però qua e la salamandra è un po
diversa perché censurato sto palazzo
sulla review quel problema se già
scritto evangelion alla è già mom mode
inquadrati
non capisco le hamster no aspetta un
valzer non so a busto tecnici potentati
tempi cioè la bandiera germania meno
male però non so dove perché la germania
è grossa e sarà berlino posso mettere
capitali cioè non lo so
franco fa franco forte io era
francoforte e tu hai baciato anche
questo sbaglio è soltanto l'apostrofo
rosa
franco forte vediamo se la via è questa
no non mi convince per niente questa mi
convince di più chissà petro mannacio
glatz queste somma per pre break singh
quindi sicuramente chi wei il capannoli
give away cioè quando tu passi di qua ti
regalano le cose
chivu equestre che capigruppo e
sicuramente inghilterra sun peter a
destra sanguin bay la baia e se una baia
vuol dire che stiamo vicino alla maglia
quindi siamo a guardare un po più
interno se ne so io non lo so qua ma
porco dimora dai no current e santa
caterina
se caterina per tutte le ferenze di aldo
giovanni e giacomo story dovunque ci sia
qualcuno in spagna giusto per suggerirmi
somme eesere m in italiano di dove
sarebbe erano soldi secondo me sarebbe
c'è il mare c'è il marmo nel mare quello
del mare non posso mari marittimo
potrebbe essere madrid marittima non lo
so non sono sicuro
bettamio malgrat malgrado tutto siamo in
spagna le battute di merda le posso
anche vita eccolo al mare si si ferma al
livello minimo
eccolo lì mare quindi è un posto di mare
i frutti di mare
l'ex dell'ausl e canestrelli col saint
german
siamo alicante la florida più o meno
mannaggia a barcellona sta per il de vos
che devo essere un po più sicuro per una
volta che hanno messo posti sicuri
era un posto sicuro la fascia ionica
posto marittima dove sono stato in
spagna era quello vabbè dai però capito
vi sia piaciuto come al senso di come io
mi piace la prossima volta faremo
soltanto streak vediamo se riesco a fare
così decente lasciato momento be like
era come sempre lo becca telecomando
secondo voi
giriamo al prossimo video bei ragazzi
[Musica]